تم إجبار كل من جين بوليبوكو وألكسندر بالافيلو على الدخول إلى إحدى
منشآت الحجر الصحي التي تديرها الحكومة
بعد أن ثبتت إصابتهما بالفيروس
وانضمما إلي الآن وأنا
أقدر حقًا
وجودكما معي جين آه لقد تم
إطلاق سراحك يوم الجمعة. أنا أفهمك  كنت
في إحدى هذه
المرافق التي تديرها الحكومة لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع ،
لقد صورت بعضًا من تجربتك
التي من الواضح أن العديد من
المواطنين الصينيين لم تكن لتعلم
أنهم قادرون على فعل ذلك ،
ولم يكن لديك أي خصوصية ، نعم أنت تدرك
أنه كان عليك تغييرها تحت ملاءات سريرك
حرفيًا ، نوع من حملها فوق
رأسك لتغيير مسار قطعة من صندوق من الورق المقوى
فوق سريرك لمحاولة حجب
مصابيح الفلورسنت لأنها
لم تنفجر طوال الأسابيع الثلاثة التي كنت
فيها
هناك وأنا أعلم أنها من بعض النواحي
كنت عدوك الرئيسي لعدم وجود كلمة أفضل ،
هل يمكنك أن تخبرني فقط عن مدى صعوبة
ذلك ،
مرحبًا جيدًا ، نعم ، مثل
مزيج من جميع العوامل التي
كنت تسميها للتو  إد أنت تعلم أنه مثل
الخصوصية التي لا تحتوي على أضواء 24 7
ولا نعرف في الأساس أي يوم من
الوقت يكون هذا أحيانًا مثل الوقت من
اليوم والضوضاء لأن هناك 4000
شخص في الداخل لذلك كل هذا نحن
الضغط كثيرًا حقًا ، أود أن أقول إن
الصحة العقلية أه من الناحية الجسدية ،
لقد كان لدينا بالكاد إمكانية الوصول إلى النظافة الأساسية ،
لذلك لم يتم الاستحمام لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع بدون
دش ، فقط أنت تعرف بعض الماء لغسل
وجهك أو غسل شعرك ،
لقد كان الأمر كذلك  تجربة سهلة
وليست ممتعة